Колишня канцлерка Німеччини Анґела Меркель краще за інших європейських політиків знає Володимира Путіна.
Вона 19 разів бувала з візитами у Москв
Від початку повномасштабної війни в Україні багато хто - у тому числі й члени її партії Християнсько-демократичний союз -
чекали від неї різкого засудження дій Росії та визнання помилок своєї політики щодо Путіна.
Але Меркель мовчить. Щоправда, експертів її мовчання не дивує.
Пані Меркель завжди вирізнялася великою, іноді навіть надто великою стриманістю та нейтралітетом.
Те, що вона зараз мовчить, навіть має сенс.
Оскільки це не справа колишньої канцлерки Німеччини активно втручатися у поточну політику.
Анґела Меркель ніколи не була багатослівною.
Вона висловлювалася лише тоді, коли це було необхідно.
Інакше вона не афішувала свою думку.
Вона також ніколи не висловлювалася про Путіна, навіть коли вона ще була на посаді.
Але вона часто спілкувалася з Путіним, це так.
Меркель залишила посаду канцлера у грудні минулого року після 16 років при владі.
Вона говорила, що планує відпочити і більше не займатися політикою.
Після нападу Росії на Україну вона, як і ще низка німецьких політиків, опинилися під вогнем критики.
Особливо жорстко це прозвучало з вуст українського президента Володимира Зеленського.
Я запрошую пані Меркель та пана Саркозі відвідати Бучу і побачити,
до чого за 14 років призвела політика поступок Росії.
Побачити на власні очі закатованих українців і українок.
Помилки політики Німеччини щодо Росії вже визнав публічно президент країни Франк-Вальтер Штайнмаєр,
який обіймав посаду міністра закордонних справ в одному з урядів Меркель.
Тим часом ексканцлерка відкинула жорстку критику на свою адресу і заявила,
що залишається прихильницею свого рішення на саміті НАТО в 2008 році в Бухаресті -
про відмову прийняти Україну в Альянс.
При цьому вона через свого представника підтримала зусилля щодо припинення війни в Україні.
У партії Меркель не вважають, що на ексканцлерці лежить частина провини за війну в Україні.
Генеральний секретар ХДС Маріо Чая наголосив, що війну розв'язав Путін та його злочинці у Кремлі.
Однак політика Меркель та її прихильників після 2014 року викликає дедалі більше запитань у німецькому суспільстві.
Особливо залежність від російського газу, яка за цей час ще більше зросла.
Це було величезною помилкою, зокрема з боку уряду Німеччини та канцлерки Меркель,
яка, як я вважаю, не мала ілюзій щодо того, з ким мала справу в особі Путіна.
Я вважаю, що вона переконалася в тому, наскільки ця людина брехлива і небезпечна,
але дешевий природний газ, дешева нафта з Росії справді були основою економічних успіхів Німеччини.
Після 2014 року Німеччині слід було жорсткіше діяти щодо Росії. Це, звичайно, не підтримали б виборці.
Тоді небагато знайшлося політиків, які чітко висловилися та закликали до посилення санкцій.
Ніхто не закликав зупинити купівлю російського газу, а це було б найрозумнішим кроком на той момент.
Все, що ми зробили відносно швидко тепер, після російського вторгнення в Україну,
треба було робити ще тоді. Якби це сталося у 14-му році, 2022-го у такому вигляді вдалося б уникнути.
Дехто вважає, що Меркель не робить різких заяв нині для того,
щоб у майбутньому, можливо, виступити в ролі посередниці на переговорах України та Росії.
Але до цього, кажуть експерти, ще поки далеко.
Хтось на кшталт Меркель, яка має символічний, але не політичний капітал, може справді з'явитися лише тоді,
коли обидві сторони захочуть вести серйозні переговори.
Україна вже готова до цього, а Росія поки що ні.
І я боюся, що до того часу в Україні проллється ще багато крові.
Крім того, малоймовірно, що Меркель зможе у чомусь переконати Путіна, вважають експерти.
Вони кажуть, що Меркель так і не зрозуміла Путіна до кінця.
Я не думаю, що можна сказати, що між ними були дружні стосунки.
Я думаю, що це були стосунки, можливо, скажімо так, підвищеної поваги.
Але чи поважає пан Путін когось нині? Не думаю.
І якщо навіть Шредеру, чия роль залишається в тіні, не вдалося переконати Путіна,
то це не вдасться й Анґелі Меркель і не вдасться нікому в найближчому майбутньому.
Офіційна представниця Меркель повідомила, що ексканцлерка поки не має наміру
висловлюватися про політику, яку вона провадила щодо Росії.